Howard do I poison car you have our
license hi
well I have a permanent but I'm taking
my road test you either tell me he
passed the written test he passed the
written test that day the learner's
permit Riley
Howard he's been driving with his
learner's permit who's driving with him
nobody okay Eric listen to me carefully
you cannot drive with just a learner's
permit you have to have a licensed
driver with you have you been on the
highway I will have to go Bengie talked
to Eric yesterday when he was driving
we're driving yesterday you liar because
it's hands foot but you just said you
never talked on the phone
wow I can't even believe this if he
passes Friday the DMV needs to be shut
down let me ask you question what's a
double solid yellow line mean you can't
cross over pretty good all right so I'll
bet you a hundred bucks he passed okay
you're on can I get it on there sure you
want another hundred yeah take your damn
right why not sorry honey
anybody else want free money wrong
Robin's handing out money to Eric you
better pass you how fast have you gotten
your car up to 170 really there's a
couple things going on with what what
Eric's saying that does not bode well
first of all he said he drove to
Connecticut the other day first of all I
don't think with your learner's permit
one state your ally but we've already
pointed that out unfortunately
unfortunately Hasmik gosh Benji said
when he spoke to him he thought he was
alone in the car yes yeah no both of
those where you been
Oh Eric is cracking on Gary now terrible
that was pretty good